I ran into a kid in Seattle or kid
twenty six-year-old at a book at a book
signing and I saw him out of the corner
of my eye standing in the corner and was
kind of frightened by him not in
physically but I mean oh god I hope it's
not a manuscript you've got to give me
and that which is he'll of course too
and the guy the finally the reading and
Andy hung around and I could feel him
out of the corner of my eye approached
me and he had me sign his book and I did
he began to leave and then he turned
around and he said I think he knew my
father and as soon as he said those
words I knew who the kid was I saw it in
his faces because he was dad in that
kid's face it was my platoon leader in
Vietnam ah and he told me over the
course of the next 20 minutes or 1/2
hour that he had the kid had been
searching for his father ever since his
father committed suicide soon after
Vietnam and had looked for his dad in
very brave cool ways he had joined the
army just to see what his father had
gone through he become a green beret to
suit his dad had been a ranger all this
tough snake eating you know stuff and he
had picked up my first book and his
father figures in the book not in always
in most laudatory ways in fact not in
laudatory ways well that encounter mean
if we want to cry if I weren't on camera
the little tears of my eyes now because
it's an example of why I began writing
in the first place I want to touch
people in a way that story's Kentucky
and I had help in the very modest way
for this fellow to fill in a gap for
this man and man who had committed
suicide before they even knew his
father's father killed himself when he
was very I think he was like six months
older eight-months very young um
encounters like that remind me of why I
began it's easy to forget why you why
you become a writer and letters I'll get
from the girlfriends of people in Iraq
or Afghanistan or the children which all
say the same thing basically I don't
know my dad he won't talk about it or my
mom in some cases largely men and we I
read your book and now I know at least
something of what he's carrying around
with him what he won't talk about and
sometimes the book will be shared with
the veteran and conversation will ensue
and that is way beyond anything I
intended in the writing of the book I
didn't intend to bring people together
or started I'm talking but I showed you
the power of literature it can it really
touches individual people realize and a
real world and contributes to their
lives it does something to their lives
that that's what I dreamed of I began
writing I dreamed of touching some 15
year old kid and Dubuque or some
grieving mother and you know Harlem
literature makes you feel if it's any
good it can make you feel a little less
alone in the world
someone else has gone through this and
it gives you some late-night company
with your memories and your sorrow
literature does touch people it's not
just to be read in English classes
you